comments in on YouTube how you doing
Jones how you doing my brother I'm good
how's my connection your it's a little
bit choppy it looks like it's coming
through though okay yeah I'm testing out
the um
mobile WiFi because I got Comcast I'm
trying to decide what I want to do sa
some money however um I've been um
W welcome to the platform thanks oh let
me give me a second shut I got yeah it
seems like there might be just a little
bit of a delay there no that's yeah I'm
sorry I had the um The View on so so
basically I want to just um
um bring something up I I I've heard you
in the past talk about the Quan um
confirming the uh the inil and the Torah
and so forth and I don't necessarily
disagree with you um I think the the
problem is um many Muslims in my opinion
I'm Muslim by the way Muslim for 20
years more than 20 years and um my
opinion is that most don't read the text
um the way they're supposed to be read
for example in verse four I mean sah
four Ana ayat 47 and it says oh you have
been given the
scripture believe in what was revealed
now what that's referring to is the
talking about the Quran number one and
why is it saying believe in what was
revealed in terms of the Quran it
further goes on to say because basically
it
confirms what you have with
you correct that's right brother you
preaching right now right no I don't I
don't preach
[Laughter]
um and so however though if you go to
verse 46 prior to that it says among
those who are
Jews there are some who displace words
from their right places so this goes
back to something you were just talking
about with um the um other gentleman
there in terms of you
know has something been changed here or
there or whatever the case might be and
I think that is it is accurate to say
that you know and not to say
intentionally let's just say give the
benefit of the doubt that it wasn't done
intentionally but people bu mistake
but if you look at some verses in the
the new the Old Testament as you would
call it in terms of like ishma and Isaac
and in the
age in the
Covenant for instance this conflict that
is going on right now um in Palestine
right about the land right and it say
you know you hear them say well you know
Abraham gave to his seed and what they
do they exclude the Arabs even though
the Arabs are the seed of Ishmael or you
know they're the C of Ishmael and
Ishmael is Abraham seed so how do you do
that you do that by misplacing
words you follow
me I understand what you're saying I I
fully disagree though okay tell me
why well so you would have to you would
have to establish that the words have
been misplaced where God clearly says
that he establishes his Covenant through
Isaac and his descendants right um and
that's the land that they'll be
receiving to Isaac's
descendants that that was actually words
that are being displaced you would have
to show me something else so the proof
the proof
is historic we look at
history and where were the Jews where
were the Jews um whether it
was after the exposion of of of of um
from Jerusalem which many Jews would
tell you that there were still Jews
there even after the Expos
of of of Jews there um for instance
during the time of prophet Muhammad
there were Jews in Yemen there were Jews
in Medina at the time was called y there
were Jews all over that area so the
Covenant was held they were still there
they never left and as it says from the
river to euph
fres we're talking about all the way
into Iraq and that's where they were
prior to the creation of this new Israel
so the Covenant was there and the
Covenant was for both of them this is
the reason why in that land you found
whether they were Christian Jews or
Muslim they were of the semetic
people so that's why I have to stop you
okay the scripture says that the land
will be given to Isaac and his
Descendants the descendants of Isaac and
that the Covenant is established with
Isaac and his descendants not is
is how do you explain then how do you
explain then all the Arabs in that land
that are desc of ish well well that's
that's an assumption that they're ones
who are descendants of of Ishmael but
that that's
nonetheless the the explanation is
simple the Bible says God says in his
Covenant that as long as you obey me you
will remain in this land but if when you
rebel against me I'll take you out of it
right now not to say that he's taking
the possession away from them it's still
theirs however he literally tells them
you don't obey my commands I will take
you from the land you will be scattered
and you will be placed in lands as
strangers right and sojourners in other
people's lands and even there will be
strangers that would occupy your land
that's in the scripture again though but
they were still in the land though
that's that's my point they were still
in the land even after some of the
exposure because all the Jews were not
were not exposed yeah there's always
there's always a Remnant there's always
a Remnant right but so right so so so
there being always a remnant of them
therefore they never left and the Arabs
were always there always there you know
so yes they were no when they were not
so so go to Isaiah go to Isaiah 42 go
Isaiah 42 that's way after that's way
after no no but no no no it doesn't
matter whether it's way after or not
we're talking about from that time on
yeah we're talking about from Genesis
from the promise all into them taking
the land and with the Exodus and then
finally taking the promised land and
then them you know going into Exile
right um in in Jeremiah and Daniel right
and then and then getting the land back
and then being integrated and mixed in
with other people all this kind of stuff
man the point is that the scripture is
clear that the Covenant is given to
Isaac um is established with Isaac and
his descendants to say otherwise would
be going against the scripture well no I
don't think it's going against scripture
at all I think there's we we obviously
have two different interpretations of
that
because what do you mean how what do you
mean what do you mean how look look what
I read what I read what I read
is the seed said the Seed of Abraham the
seed your seed his is is is ishma and
Isaac no it's not did did you know this
the word seed there is
singular it's not plural it's you see
it's not seeds it's your seed it doesn't
listen here's the thing we're reading
English we definitely reading English so
it says seed you can't you can't you
can't exclude you can't exclude you
can't exclude because even in that
scripture it talks about those who are
those who are circumcised yeah but it
doesn't say that they're the ones who
have the Covenant established they're
just because they are with Abraham then
they are the males that are with Abraham
whether they're his sons or they're his
servants they get circumcised if they're
with Abraham that doesn't mean that they
have the Covenant or they're the the
Covenant but the Covenant but clearly
talk it gives him the Covenant they
could have they could have left they
could have not been circumcised and left
Abraham's Camp
right huh they could have you're right
yeah yeah so so that doesn't mean that
they were part of the the Covenant was
given to Abraham established with his
seed singular in the Hebrew and that
seed specifically as he says he names
him is Isaac specifically there's no
ambiguity about that to throw to throw
ishma in there would be that's that's
blatantly going against the scripture no
I don't think so I think again back hold
on no hold on hold on y
yo thank you so going back to my my my
point that I was making from the very
beginning all right and maybe we can
visit this another time because I don't
have much time is when the Quran States
among those Jews there are some who
displace words from their right places
so therefore
therefore okay in the Bible There Are
Places there that are not
accurate that's not what it says no no
if if you hold on time's up if you move
if I take a word if I take a word and
move it from one place to another it's
no longer it's no longer the same
message therefore it's no longer
accurate is that correct hold on the qu
the question Mr Jones is how are they
displacing words from the right places
are they doing it textually or are they
doing it orally by lying about what the
text says okay
right good question that's a good
question that's a good question and
here's how that that that that question
is answered if I continue to tell a
lie that lie for many becomes the truth
and what and at some point it will be
written down as it is being told and you
can't say has come
on come on bro come
on seriously that's a big assumption no
no that's a are you serious I'm dead
serious Mr Jo even okay let's look okay
let's let's look at today let's look at
today that doesn't help in politics in
politics politicians lie who prints the
LIE the media they print it right even
though it's a lie so you can't say that
you can't say that back then or any time
if someone tells a lie and keeps telling
that lie those who are going to hear
that lie would not write it down would
not believe it okay so you're assuming
that just because someone tells a lie
and it gets multiplied that people write
it down let me even grant you that
people write the lie down that doesn't
mean that the actual true Torah or
scripture has been infiltrated and
Rewritten and messed up they would just
now have what they wrote with their own
selves a fake thing that they say us
from from God that doesn't mean the
actual scripture is
touched when you say the actual
scripture what do you mean I mean the
actual Torah the book The Torah and the
gospel the actual Bible that they had
with them that the Quran says is true
and it's confirming right what they had
with them is untouched it's uncorrupted
it's preserved now say that's not what
the crean saying that's exactly what the
Quran says no it doesn't say that at all
you just read it no it does not no I 447
no 4 here's what 447 says and I'll read
it to you again it says all you who
believe oh wait a minute oh you all you
have been given the scripture believe in
what has been revealed confirming what
is with you now understand something
understand something understand
something thean does not reveal
everything that you have it only it only
confirms some of what you have okay
specifically
and no no no no hold on he's breaking
out dang
it very specific the laws I'll give you
one example wait
wait stop stop Slow Down slow down slow
down where does it say that the Quran is
confirming some of what they
have where is the word sum of what they
have pop
no no no no no no see I'm not going to
play that game because I I've watched
you so I'm going to focus on I'm going
to focus on what I know the Quran says
no we know the word some not in there no
no no no no no no if you watch me then
you know how I am you know that I like
to no no no no the Quran clearly shows
you it talks about the Commandments law
no it doesn't it says
let me give you an example let me no
before you try to give an example we
have to establish this
first so we both agree that it doesn't
say it's confirming some of what they
have it says it's confirming what they
have with them period right okay no it
says it it says it says what you have
with you understand this is what you
need this is what you understand if the
if the Quran States if the Quran if the
if the state here's what the first okay
the first one it says this it says
believe believe it says believe and what
we have revealed confirming now
confirming what bring it up believe in
what we have
believe believe in what have been
revealed right now let's start with
there the only way you will believe in
the Quran is if it matches
up if it doesn't you're not going to
believe it that's that correct exactly
that's why I don't believe the Quran it
doesn't match up so so so so so here's
so here's where the match is at okay
what do you mean if there's some parts
where it doesn't match then it's it's
false the Quran is not false the
statement the statement of the Bible is
false and I'm gonna give you the example
when in the Quran says it's confirming
the Bible can I can can let me can I
give you the proof for can I give you
the pro yeah please explain this it says
that it's confirming what is with them
which is the Bible no the Bible not no
no not the Bible this okay good hold on
please please stop this is why we have
to take it step by step so now you're
saying it's not the Bible it doesn't say
the Bible I got you I got you I got you
so let's what was with them what was
with them
you've watched me enough you can have
you can have what you consider the Bible
have that let's let's let's take what
what you have with you currently correct
all right the tire the entire book the
entire book when you go into the book
you have to read it and confirm what the
Quran is confirming no for example let
me see if I can't give you an example
for you to understand then it's not
going to work this not not gonna Happ
you don't you don't have to give an
example when you say something as clear
as it's self-explain to what you're
saying that you don't have to ere
explain stuff no no no I'm gonna explain
to you I'm going to explain I'm going to
explain to you you can cut me off if you
want I'm gonna explain to you two verses
one from the Bible and one from the
Quran I don't need that that's see
that's I'm tell you I'm telling you I'm
telling
you Jones slow
down what was with them what was with
them
what was with them if I have if
you whatever it was that they had they
called the inel or they called the Bible
my point is my point is that the Bible
no no but no it does not confirm the
Bible okay I'm ask ask ask
again first and foremost it says it says
alab the book what was that what was
that which book you tell me
you say
the you're wasting my time man wasting
my time because you don't want me to
give you the evidence that the Quran has
I'm G give you one last chance what was
with them the K the book which B what
was that what book I don't know you tell
me oh you don't know so how do you know
it wasn't the Bible because no no no
you're saying the Bible you said Bible
how do you no this what I'm saying you
said it's not the Bible you said it's
not the Bible Mr Jones So when you say
it's not the Bible that means that you
know what it was since you're able to
say it does notan it does not mean that
it does not mean that how do you know
was Bible how do you know the Bible it
does not mean that if I say that it
wasn't that because I'm saying that
based upon the fact that it doesn't say
Bible it says kab it says book
know for for for the listeners here kab
in Arabic just means book we absolutely
that's what it means absolutely okay how
do you know that the KE
the book there was not the Bible how do
you know it was and that's it thank you
how do you know was I'll tell you why
I'll tell you how I know and then this
will be it I know because the Quran
specifically mentions the Torah which is
in the Bible the gospel which is in the
Bible the zor the psalm let me finish
let me finish let me finish which is in
the Bible the Psalms that's in the Bible
all of these books are in the Bible
That's how I know in the century they
have mat
Mar here the problem with here's the
problem with that state so do you see
how I was able to tell you how I know no
no you're no no no but you're concluding
that all those books were at one point
always one book when we know that's not
the truth and the reason why we know
that's not the truth because the Jews at
the time didn't follow the NG except for
those who followed Jesus so they didn't
both have they both were carrying around
what you call the Bible the the Jews
have the Torah and those who follow
Jesus have had theia whether it was inv
writing or not so then why is it that
the Jews and the Christians are called
together the people of the book
because because of the mere fact that
the the mere fact the mere fact that
both peoples both both people have
attached themselves to the book that God
has sent down and what was the book that
the Jews
inel again I'm going back to the same
what I said before you're trying you're
trying to conclude that all these books
you you trying to that all these books
were at at one from the very beginning
one book come on what was the book that
the Jews and the Christians attached
themselves to what was that they called
the they called the but it's a what what
did the Jews and the Christians call
it you call today the
Bible so the Quran is talking about the
Bible correct no no it's not because
it's not no it's no it's not no it's Mr
Jones Mr Jones I have say respectfully I
have to end this conversation yeah yeah
you would you would because you wouldn't
let me give the proof well well you
didn't have any proof when I asked you
would let me give the proof you would
let me the proof you didn't have any the
proof you wouldn't give me let me get
the proof thanks for coming
that was Mr Jones everybody that's an
Jones um you know you know he said that
the that the other Muslims they don't go
and actually read the scripture they say
things that's not really true about
about the Quran and not reading it
carefully but then our own Mr Jones
himself added to the Quran by saying
it's it's not confirming everything that
they have it's confirming some things
that they have when it doesn't say that
it's stuff let's let's put it up on the
screen again it says believe in what we
have sent down confirming what is with
you does it say some of what is with you
a little bit of what is with
you most of what is with you nope
whatever they had that was in their
possession the Quran is confirming it
period
maybe this may maybe that's not enough
if may maybe that ain't enough maybe
that's not enough let's let's let's go
everywhere may maybe maybe that may may
maybe that wasn't it man may maybe that
wasn't enough for him to see where I'm
coming from maybe that wasn't enough
let's see here let's let's let's see
what this says this is chapter 2 verse
41 and believeing what I have sent down
confirming that which is with you and
brackets they put already that's crazy
that which is already with you and be
not the first to disbelieve in it
believe in what some of it wait wait
according to Mr Jones here I can disbel
in some of it while believing in other
parts of it if I'm going with Mr
Jones
right but let's see what the Quran says
about those who do what Mr Jones was
just doing we're going to stay in
Chapter 2 come on
man come on man now I didn't I didn't I
didn't treat him like how I usually
treat the you know the rest of the
Muslim he's you know he's my Elder and
you know there's some there's some
respect there you know so I ain't gonna
talk to him like how I talk to the other
Muslims however Still Still Still gota
Still gotta take the the an to class man
I see you smiling over there uncle uncle
Jones all right so let's put this verse
up man I can't I can't hear you brother
I can't hear you when you're talking
like down there I can't hear
you but this is what it says chapter 2
verse
89 and when there came a book
confirming that which was with them what
nah but what does the Quran say about
those who pick and
choose what does it say so do you
believe in part of the
scripture do you believe in part of the
scripture and disbelieve in
part Mr Jones Uncle Jones are you
picking and choosing what you what you
decide is is is true of the scripture
man are you believing some of it but not
the
rest then what is the recompense for
those who do that among you accept
disgrace in this worldly life and on the
day of Resurrection they will be sent
back to the severest of punishment I
don't want you to get in trouble with
Allah Mr
Jones I don't want you to get in
trouble I don't want you to have the
severest of punishments upon
you the scriptures ain't a buffet where
you say that's right that's wrong that's
right that's wrong not a according to
your book your book says you can't pick
and choose either you believe in all of
it or you believe in none of it and if
you don't believe in none of it he going
to Chuck you to the fire